as a teacher I'm all about learning when
I come to work I have lots of jobs here
and there but my chief purpose as a
teacher is to help people learn so I
watch people I notice the things that
help people learn and the things that
don't at this stage in my career I
estimate that I personally talked
somewhere between 600 and 700 students
and by doing that I've noticed some
patterns in particular a set of
misconceptions that people believe about
learning at about school that I've
repeatedly had to show students aren't
true so here are five lives we believe
about learning and school number one
practice makes perfect
practice makes perfect how many times
you heard this one is practically the
mantra of sport coaches who run drills
and math teachers who said exercises the
reason why it's so widely believed is
because it's so close to the truth you
know when we try to master a skill the
way we do it is by doing that skill over
and over again until becomes familiar
what's really happening your brain is
that different parts of it are being
linked together by connections called
sign answers and the more times you
repeat the process the stronger those
synapses become the stronger they are
the more automatic that skill ears in
fact they become what we call habits is
so ingrained into our minds that we can
even do them to an extent without
thinking but as we all know very well we
can form bad habits just as easily as we
form good ones just because you practice
something repeatedly that doesn't
guarantee that what you're practicing is
good there's any music teacher will tell
you practicing the wrong techniques will
land you in more trouble than if you
hadn't practiced at all because you'll
get very good at doing things in an
ineffective way and I see this all the
time in math students do their book work
but they don't set out their work
properly or they don't take the time to
draw proper diagrams they tell me oh
don't worry I know how I'm supposed to
do it and I'll do it right on the test
but invariably they don't practice makes
habits and they take those bad habits
right into the exam hall then wonder why
they didn't
the test see the point is practice does
not make perfect practice makes habit so
be very careful with it number two if
you want to do well you should sleep
less and work more sleep less work more
this trance tends to start around United
ten and as students move into the C
years and university just gets worse the
logic goes like this I have so much
stuff to do so much material to learn
and I know that the best way to learn is
to do the work but I don't have enough
time I need more time where am I going
to get it I know I'll sleep less and for
a little while it works you put some
late nights you get stuff done and it
seems to be effective the problem is
you're fooling yourself particularly in
the long run your whole body but
especially your brain needs sleep the
way it needs what are oxygen and other
nutrients without them it doesn't
function properly and we've all
experienced this before and I don't just
mean the times when you feel tired it's
the moments when you're sitting in class
or the teachers talking and you
understand the individual words coming
out of their mouth but if you had to
explain what it all meant you'd have no
idea what's happening you can't
concentrate because your mind isn't
rested even when you can concentrate
later on you'll have times when you
think to yourself am I learned this yeah
I vaguely remember reading or hearing
something about this but I don't get it
you turned your friend and they tell you
yeah we covered this last week you were
there what's happening is that your
brain is getting stuffed with all of
this knowledge but it cut hold on to it
it can't retain it you know it can't
because one of the chief types where
your brain forms those new connections
and remembers things is when you're
asleep so you are robbing your brain of
time to take all that information and
turn it into knowledge if you spend all
day in class and it's been hours
studying and night without getting a
decent night's sleep it's as though
you've brought like a thousand books for
a library and then said to the librarian
look you've got five minutes to put this
all away he'll look at you and say
forget it I can't manage that I'll put
some stuff in the shelves but don't
expect it to be in any kind of decent
order where you'll be able to find it
you need it you know it definitely don't
expect me to deal with all of it
okay yes work hard put the hours in but
you can't afford to do it at the cost of
sleep number three you should give up
sport to maximize studies stop
exercising spend more time at your desk
now the biggest culprits here usually
you're 12 students who for the first
time but not forced to do sport and then
you think yes I've been waiting 17 years
for this opportunity sayonara sport the
problem here is that not only is a lack
of exercise bad for your body in general
but regular physical activity is
actually vital to peak brain performance
getting your heart rate up regularly
helps to ensure good blood flow oxygen
to the brain which helps it work more
effectively and assuming that you're
generally fit enough to not die when you
do it a 20-minute walk or ride has been
scientifically proven to elevate all
kinds of brain activity and clear the
mind giving up sport robs you of that it
doesn't mean you necessarily have to
commit to a weekly great sport or
whatever to get decent exercise but it's
certainly not a bad idea and you need to
get that physical activity somewhere
into your regular schedule number four
tutoring solves all problems ok tutoring
if you're struggling or if you want to
get ahead you should go to tutoring now
I've heard that lots of times don't get
me wrong
tutoring can be a really helpful thing
when I was at university I did some
individual tutoring and I wouldn't have
gone to the effort if I didn't think
that I could actually benefit people but
by and large as a teacher I see that
tutoring can cause problems for students
just as much as it solves them you know
for starters it takes up precious time
in an already full week I talked about
how losing sleeps a bad idea and
sometimes people will lose several hours
a week to tutoring that will be much
better spent in other ways not only that
but many tutoring places work on the
premise of covering topics and skills
before students meet them in their
regular school classes I understand the
logic behind this and I definitely agree
that that's sometimes an idea or concept
leaves time to settle
before it really clicks and so the
earlier introduced to it the better but
considering the students and generally
studying five to ten other completely
different subjects and then learning
mattes in two or more different topics
at the same time I see so many people
would just end up confused and then mix
up formulas and methods they learn
techniques and algorithms like like the
rules of differentiation without first
developing the conceptual understanding
to make sense of what it all means they
develop inconsistent ways of setting up
and they get taught techniques that are
accepted in some places but not in
others
now I know cheery can be helpful but it
can also be a recipe for disaster you
need to be very careful if you decide to
spend time and money on it
lastly number five the best way to learn
is to study the best way to learn is to
read do exercises and make notes and
complete past papers I mean this is a
no-brainer right of course the best way
to learn something is to study it how
else do you learning the entire which I
swear realizes student myself but only
really got to appreciate fully once I
started teaching is that the best way to
learn is not to study the best way to
learn is to explain you see study is
about passively taking in information
and yes you should do that you should
read and do exercises and make notes and
complete past papers but those aren't
the best tools you have really
developing understanding the best way is
to take what you've read at Hertz sieve
and then try to explain how it works and
why to someone else let me tell you when
we study we basically think and work
till we get to a level understanding
where we can you know in maths for
example do the assign questions and once
we get to that level and are
consistently getting the right answer
something we tend to move on but the
problem is that that level of
understanding isn't all the way there
yet the acid test is when you get given
a similar kind of problem but it's
worded slightly differently or placed in
a slightly different context
and then we get confused and don't know
how to approach it what happened we
didn't really understand what we are
doing all we did was plaster a set of
steps a recipe for how to solve a
particular kind of question
it only takes a very basic level of
skill to master recipe you just have to
read the instructions and go through
them in order like I can bake a cake or
make a sticky date pudding if you give
me a decent recipe but I don't really
understand anything about baking or
desserts I don't know what baking powder
does or why you need a certain ratio of
flour to water or what difference it
makes if you add eggs or don't I am just
following the recipe and sometimes we're
like that with Matt's problems we're
just going through the motions now what
I've discovered as a teacher is that the
best way to really know if you
understand something is to stand up in
front of others and try to explain it
that's when you really find out if you
get it because someone will look at you
and say but why did you do that or why
do I get the wrong note ah if I do it
this way and if you can't provide a
response that's what you can tell you
need to go back and work on you need to
take those points work through them
study them until you can explain them
and then understand them it was Albert
Einstein who said you know if you can't
explain it simply you don't understand
it well enough I think he was exactly
right
so practice doesn't make perfect it
makes happen don't sacrifice sleep to
get more done because you'll end up
learning less stay physically active to
keep your brain in peak condition be
very cautious with tutoring and if you
really want to learn something explain
it